it was the breaking point for many of
these migrant workers stranded in
India's financial capital a few hours
after Prime Minister Narendra Modi
announced the lockdown will continue for
another two and a half weeks at least
1,500 people gathered outside a railway
station
they've lost their jobs and their demand
and transport to take them to their home
states we aren't getting anything here
the government promised to provide money
and other amenities but nothing has been
delivered yet we have nothing to do now
we've got small children and they aren't
getting anything to eat what should we
do
Mumbai police deployed extra officers in
the Bandra area of the city bus the
local police tried to reason with them
but a part of group became aggressive
and police had to use my force to
disperse them this is the third protest
by migrant workers in recent days last
week workers in the city of Surat in
Gujarat state threw stones and set tires
and vegetable carts on fire they said
their salaries hadn't been paid they
didn't have enough food and wanted to go
home and a day later police in Delhi say
migrant workers staying in a homeless
shelter set the building on fire after
fighting with the shelter staff over
food police said four people jumped into
a nearby river after they were beaten by
staff one person drowned
Prime Minister Modi acknowledged of the
lockdown to combat code 19 has been
particularly hard on India's millions of
migrant workers and daily wage earners
Madan bong I am well aware of the
difficulties you have faced some for
food some for movement from place to
place and others for staying away from
homes and families hundreds of thousands
of migrant workers started walking home
after the lockdown was first announced
three weeks ago leading to the biggest
movement of people across the country in
decades and defeating the purpose of the
lockdown the government had announced
aid for 800 million of India's poor but
it's clear that help isn't reaching
everyone and Tuesday's protests show
people aren't waiting on the promises of
more help to come
Elizabeth puranam al-jazeera
Kelly